ladies and gentlemen would you give a
big round of applause now big welcome to
the CEO of Caesars Entertainment ladies
and gentlemen mr. Tony Rony oh good
morning everybody
how cool is this thank you so much for
joining us on this very momentous moment
and thank you very much Wayne mr. Las
Vegas for helping us reopen Caesars
Palace a quick little historical note
Caesars Palace opened in August of 1966
and never closed its doors for 54 years
until a couple of months ago and over
that time those 54 years some of the
greatest moments in Las Vegas history
Evel Knievel Muhammad always some of the
greatest entertainers I can't tell you
how excited we are to start the next 54
years of incredible moments and
experiences and memories for thousands
of thousands of customers
I would be remiss if I didn't take a
moment obviously the country is going
through a couple of very difficult
situations and I just hope and pray that
that all of us collectively can get
through this and keep our hearts open to
all the indifference that's going on and
make the world a better place this is a
catalyst site I did want to take a
moment to mention that but with that I
know you didn't come here to listen to
me talk so we'd like to get the next 54
years roll it we have been Lapine who's
going to be our first customer in making
our first major
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]